hi everyone welcome to our homeroom live
stream we have a very exciting
conversation coming up sal here from
khan academy in case you all don't know
me we're gonna have a conversation with
chancellor robert jones from the
university of illinois uh urbana
champaign and it's going to be really
interesting because university of
illinois is
really
putting their best foot forward to do
testing contact tracing and give as
close to
a normal experience as possible so
there's going to be some really
interesting questions the whole country
is really looking at university of
illinois at urbana-champaign to
understand how this can be done well
but before we get to that i will make my
standard announcements first of all a
reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization we can only
exist through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
going to khan academy.org
donate i also want to give a special
shout out to several organizations that
have helped support khan academy we were
running at a deficit even before the
covid crisis but then with the crisis
our deficit only grew because of
increased server costs and we're trying
to accelerate a bunch of content so
special thanks to bank of america
google.org att fastly novartis and the
many other supporters at all levels
who've allowed khan academy to get to
where it is today uh but we need more
help so if you're in a position to do so
please think about doing that so with
that i'm excited to introduce chancellor
robert jones from the university of
illinois urbana-champaign thanks so much
for joining us chancellor
so thank you very much for the
opportunity glad to be here
so maybe a good place to start you know
we're back to school the big debate both
in k-12 and in higher education is
to have physical classes not to have
physical classes to have hybrid classes
tell us your thought process the
university of illinois
urbana-champaign's thought process as
you went into this back to school and
how are you all approaching it
well it became very clear to us as we
transitioned very quickly over the
course of about 12 days
back in march uh from our traditional
face-to-face education to more remote
education and as soon as we got to
graduation our virtual graduation we
start to immediately pivot and start to
focus uh very very sincerely and
rigorously
on uh
what the model should look like for the
fall
we quickly resolved that based on our
own analysis about the value of both the
in-class room and the learning that
occurs outside of the classroom that we
should try to
move towards some form of face-to-face
education
and we started to hear from our students
who were anxious
to come back to campus the majority of
them were pretty much insistent on
being back on campus and maybe some
blended form but back on campus to have
a chance to be among their friends and
colleagues and really be part of that
uniquely transformative uh
exciting environment that exists on
university campuses so the fundamental
question became how could we do that in
an effective way uh my provost and chief
academic as officer andreas canelaris
former dean of my engineering school
uh began to
pose that question to several of our
most outstanding innovative scientists
and the first person he talked to
was um marty burke who is the associate
dean of our medical school uh he's uh
a biochemist chemist as well as a an md
and marty put together in a very short
period of time a multi-disciplinary team
of more than 100 individuals across
veterinary medicine with paul
hergenrother and tim fenn
who were veterinary medicine cancer
researchers they all came together with
their multi-disciplinary teams and
pretty quickly came up with this testing
protocol because provost angularis was
very insistent that if we came back
together in a hybrid form of education
or completely face to face we needed a
test that was more rigorous than what
was generally available uh because we
had enough evidence to think that
testing was going to be absolutely
critical prerequisite
for us coming back
and so i can fill in more detail but
that was our thinking was that
some form of face-to-face education was
the best model for this university but
more importantly the best model for our
students and so we had to innovate to
create this
world-class and
saliva based testing that no one else uh
has exactly been able to do this at the
scale and at the
way that we've gone about doing it
now this is what's really interesting
about this i think everyone would agree
that the in-person experience in college
it's hard to replace you can do
something on distance learning maybe get
some of your academic learning but the
immersive experience you can't have so i
think everyone's there but what's really
incredible what y'all have done you know
some people have just kind of taken the
leap of faith and said let's cross our
fingers and hope all that goes well and
those are a lot of the universities that
are now having to send kids back home a
couple weeks in but y'all said
we can actually develop our own test a
high quality sensitive test
and administer it and i believe y'all
are administering it to every member of
your community every three days
every member of our community every
three to four days so twice a week
required mandatory testing of our
students our faculty and our staff
and we have test and capability that to
do
at least 10 000 tests per day in order
to cover those cohorts
and
several days this week and last week we
did 18 000 tests
last monday and the money before that
and so at this juncture we're
approaching probably
140-150 000 tests that we've done since
july
and the rigorous testing protocol and
the fact that the saliva based test
is innovative in terms that it
really cuts out a lot of these supply
chain issues that it would be that have
become problematic with the saliva based
with the nasopharyngeal test
a lot of the reagent steps have been cut
out and you basically dribble uh
about a teaspoon full a half a teaspoon
full into
a test tube
and then that's
heated to deactivate the virus a buffer
is added and it goes directly onto this
machine we call an rt pcr
and so it cuts out enormous amount of
time
it is cost effective it only costs a
fraction of the cost of
the nasopharyngeal test
is scalable
and uh it gives us the capacity to test
more than our 100 to run a more than 100
000 test every week and if we do this
thing called pooling we could actually
do 20 000 testing per day if we have to
and so the major difference as well is
that is scalable it's cost effective you
don't need trained medical personnel to
administer it
and i haven't had the nasopharyngeal
test but i understand it's not the most
pleasant thing to do in the world
i really understand that there's other
things y'all are doing as well but this
test that y'all developed
what is the how quickly do you all get
the results
you know uh in an ideal situation the
results come back as uh quickly as five
uh six hours or so
uh but as uh shouldn't take any longer
than 24 hours to get to test results
which are absolutely critical to be able
to notify people
to initiate our both our digital contact
tracing which i'd like to talk about a
little bit later as well as the physical
contact tracers which allows us to be
able to notify people early get those
individuals in isolation and those that
they've been associated with in
quarantine
and so quick turnaround is absolutely
key
because as you know with the
nasopharyngeal test
is not just ours and many far too many
cases it's been days to get the results
back which creates an environment where
you have no way
of mitigating the spread of the disease
and we were originally going to test
once per week but a lot of data coming
out from other researchers and our own
researchers clearly showed that our
modeling worked by our biophysicists
nigel
goldenfield and sergey uh masloffs
clearly showed that if you want to be
able to mitigate the spread you need to
be able to test those that are just
showing or just column accumulating
virus in their saliva as well as those
who have accumulated enough virus that
they can spread it to others and so the
three to four day testing protocol was
the best way to do that and to mitigate
it and uh
it's shown to be effective it's allowed
us to do broad-based surveillance
testing
and let me just mention uh the past week
or so we have been doing 20 of all the
tests in the state of illinois
and two percent of all the testing in
the entire country
and so this test is absolutely amazing
and it actually is kind of served as a
canary in the coal mine for us too
because we do so much testing and do so
and get the results back so rapidly
a few days ago we started to see
signs of a potential rise in the number
of positive cases
so it's critically important that
another aspect of this test is that it
actually has a canary in a coal mine to
let you know well beforehand before you
get to that five or eight or
seven or ten percent
positivity across your population you
have early warning enough to mitigate uh
that rise and those are some steps that
uh that were announced yesterday so
it is uh it's a game changer we think
for this university and potentially a
game changer for the state
and for the nation so we're very very
excited about it
and i definitely want to get into the
contact racing because that's also
another very important piece of y'all's
uh the way you're tackling this but
we're getting a bunch of questions off
of facebook and youtube on just
geeking out a little bit more on the
test itself on the accuracy you know
brian sway uh what is the accuracy
what's the false positive false negative
rate maria k stumpf asking essentially
the same question from facebook so what
do you all know about the false positive
and false negative rate of these tests
we know that the false positive rate is
extremely low you know there's no way to
have a zero percent false positive but i
can tell you it is extremely low and
we've done this by spiking saliva
samples with the virus and with
different viral loads and it clearly
shows and then comparing them against
other
rtpcr tests and it clearly shows that
our test has an extremely low cost false
positive rates and that's one of the
things that we are very very excited
about uh in order to get our uh
our uh emergency use authorization um
with our partnership with yale
university
we had to do what is called a bridging
study to leverage off of their approval
they think they got their approval maybe
on a friday and by partnering with them
we had our approval by the next
wednesday the governor call a big news
conference et cetera et cetera
and one of the things that bridging
study showed
is that our test
is able to detect a very very low viral
load
a fraction of what other tests
uh would
most other tests would not be able to
detest a viral load at the
number of virus per milliliter sample
that we're able to do
so it's very very
accurate it's very sensitive in fact
the comparison with the yell test as a
benchmark for our bridging study
uh shows that it's about eight times
more sensitive
uh than the yale test and we know it's
much more
accurate in terms of predicting positive
cases
because one of the concerns about the
nasopharyngeal test it's generally known
that uh
percent accuracy is uh less than what
we're experiencing
and there is the ongoing problem say for
example if you uh devour load apparently
is much higher in saliva because that is
the predominant way that the disease is
spread
and our studies and analysis would
indicate that one of the reasons
that some people are having a problem
that even after they are no longer
symptomatic
apparently have recovered from covet 19
if they go back to get a subsequent uh
nasopharyngeal test it will still come
back positive because we think the nasal
cavity
perhaps is has some remnant virus that
may longer be active whereas saliva has
predominantly active an active viral
load so there are a lot of reasons that
gives this test a comparative advantage
it has allowed us because of this uh
predictive capabilities as well as scale
and the number of people we can test has
allowed us to do what no other
university is doing and that is wide
scale surveillance testing of everybody
in the community and hopefully will
allow us to mitigate this
rise
in our positivity rate that was much
higher than what we had predicted
but we think we can get our arms around
it in the next few days and if not the
next week
and and so first of all i mean the
sensitivity i think matters a lot that
the false negatives are the the most
dangerous because obviously then someone
can go out and spread it without knowing
it so that that's really powerful tell
us a little bit about the contact
tracing because this is really you know
there's two pillars to this maybe a
third are on behavior but the second one
is contact tracing
yeah you thought you're absolutely right
we didn't just develop one of the most
innovative saliva based tests in the in
the world
uh concurrent with that uh part of this
our whole strategy is an integrated
system of saliva based testing
integrated with a app that we now call
safe
safe
safer illinois
which grew out of a conversation that i
had with one of our alums who
uh developed the uh
the whole uh integrated fan experience
for the san francisco 49ers a guy named
john paul and he talked to myself in the
provost about a year
and a half ago when we were out visiting
about if we were interested in a
app-based strategy to improve the
student experience on campus improve
advising
improving the fan experience about
ordering tickets what to do over the
weekend what to do at any point in time
and so we'd already built out the
illinois app and as soon as kobet 19 hit
uh
john paul collaborated with bill
sullivan one of our professors over in
engineering and they created ultimately
what is now called a safer in illinois
app that is built on a platform that we
are calling rockwire
but the key part of it is that it allows
a bluetooth enabled capability
that uh basically when you sign up you
download this uh this app
it allows to use the bluetooth
capability
so that if ultimately you test positive
or someone that you've been in around
for
uh you know short period of time
it can identify off of those signals and
allow us to do uh kind of a digital
bluetooth enabled contact tracing as
well
and we've had a pretty high level of
people that have signed up for that
and of course you can turn it on and off
if you want you can set your sensitivity
level but most people a significant
number of folks in our community uh hire
enough
participation in this to allow us to do
both kind of quote unquote digital
contract tracing and to leverage that
against the collaboration we have with
the illinois public health department
that has allowed us to hire
more than 100 physical contact tracers
and we just made a commitment to hire 35
more so it is an integrated system that
we've delivered of the test results once
they come back from the lab they go to
uh our medical mckinley health services
and the positive cases you're notified
either by your cell phone because you're
supposed to enter your cell phone number
and then this app basically has with it
a critically important uh
tool as well
that's leveraged off of this app and
that is it gives your covet status
in terms of are you given permission to
enter a building or not it doesn't tell
you or the person that's looking at it
or whether you're positive or negative
but it does
enable our students and everybody is
required to do this faculty staff and
students before you enter building
before you can enter a classroom
particularly you have to display what we
call your entry card and your boarding
pass either digitally on your
smart device or we actually have a
system you can print it out hard copy
and it says access granted or accessed
denied and
chancellors are are not exempt
if you bear with me in just a moment i
can give you uh if you're interested a
visualization of that
i just came back from giving my saliva
test a few minutes ago
and hopefully you can see that robert
jones has been granted access to
uh buildings on campus and so
everybody in our community if you're
going to class you have to show this in
order to make this work
we had to invest
in hiring between 300 and 400
individuals mostly students some folk
from the community that we call wellness
wellness associates
uh and their job is to be in front of
classrooms to
check these apps we absolutely so we
require wearing masks inside of the
classroom so to be perfectly candid with
you
being inside one of our classrooms two
things we know that as far as humanly
possible 99.9 percent of the folks in
there
are covet-free they're negative as well
as we require people notwithstanding
that everybody has to wear a mess the
full time that you're in the classroom
including the instructor the professors
and when they're speaking in order to
not disadvantage people that may have
hearing issues
they have to they can take their mess
off and put mask off or face covering
off and put on a
text glass face shield but we're
creating a safe environment as we can
inside of the classroom and even between
classes as i walked over to get my
saliva test about an hour or so ago
you could see small group of people
sitting around on campus and i'm very
very moved and touched by the fact of
the
large compliance
that people use hard to see someone
walking on campus and not have on their
face covering and if they're walking
along or walking with somebody that
lives in their roommate of someone
they'll be chatting but you could check
just look down at their hands and you'll
see they have those face coverings that
they in their hands and i can tell you
can't tell you how many times i've
observed as they are approaching others
they don't know they put the face
covering on and that's become part of
the culture of keeping themselves safe
but also protecting the health and
safety of others
there's so many questions this is really
you know impressive you know a couple of
quite a question from facebook jessica
fox asking how are students quarantined
after positive tests and maybe you know
i'd love your answer to that one because
you know fauci has talked about some
college sending kids home that's not a
good idea because that just infects
everyone else uh and
well let's just start there i have other
questions yeah yeah we're not sending uh
young people home but i agree that
that's a bad idea and so a key part of
what we decided to do quite early
that we knew that there were going to be
students testing positive when the first
week that they came back
and uh as well as that would be uh
positive cases uh
uh uh you know as we began the first
week of class
and uh so what we uh have done about uh
isolation is that as soon as that test
results
up until actually yesterday when we made
another announcement the results went to
the local public health department they
were the first line of contact of
calling up trying to contact those
individuals
and let them know what they needed to do
to isolate that went to the housing and
we created an environment where students
would quarantine or isolate in place
uh with very strict instructions about
not violating isolation or quarantining
and we set aside
about five percent of our uh rooms and
our housing residential hall
uh for this purpose we just decided to
move that almost to 10 percent we don't
have a problem
with uh
of expanding beyond that capacity so
it's not a capacity issue at the moment
as well as the local public health
department has rented hotels
rooms
within the community to also
accommodate those particularly the ones
that may have difficulty isolating
because they have a roommate or because
other kinds of circumstances so we've
been very very aggressive about the uh
isolation and quarantining peace
and one of the things we
have done to increase
uh the rate at which we can contact
those that have tested positive i think
we were putting a bit of burden on the
public health folks to do this alone uh
so again the same team that
created what we call
shield t3 that's the formal name or
shield for our saliva based test
yesterday came up with the brilliant
idea of something they're calling shield
30 where we have 30 additional people to
assist
the public health department within 30
minutes of one of our undergraduate
students in particular receiving a
positive test result
someone is trying to reach them either
by phone or by text message
within 30 minutes because we need to
make sure we identify and contact those
folks as quickly as possible because
otherwise they will be walking around
the campus in some cases unknowingly
potentially spreading covet 19. so we've
been very rigorous about this and keep
innovating around it to make sure we
have the most rigorous uh system of
isolation and identifying those that are
positive
uh using digital and physical contact
tracing to quarantine those that they
come in contact with
and i mean this is incredible i've
really really two questions i have many
many more but you know the first one is
i know you all have had i mean it's good
that you're identifying these cases and
you've had several hundred
at what point do you know that this is
working or not it's sustainable is there
our job thresholds that he's like if x
percentage of the population starts
testing positive we might have to go to
distance learning how are you all
thinking about that
well the way that we're thinking about
it is uh and i try to remind people it's
been a data-driven strategy that has
gotten us to this point to make us feel
comfortable with opening up in the fall
and it will be a data driven strategy
that causes us to make a different
decision a case in point one of the
things that we announced yesterday was
that we were asking our students all of
our students everybody in the community
uh to kind of limit their activity to
essential activities only uh for the
next 14 days why
because um
you know we were very surprised and
disappointed that a very very small
number of folks in our community were
breaking isolation
uh they were leaving their isolation
site
to
go get a burger or go do whatever they
thought they could do
and
we had to send a very strong message
that that's not acceptable and those
that continue to do that uh are being
suspended from the university there was
another small group of students who
somehow had misinterpreted the
cdc guidelines
that in some states in some communities
allows you to go back and get tested
and test out of
an isolation or a quarantine environment
and we had to send a very strict and
stern message that no remind you that
the cdc also gave local governments
local jurisdiction to put in more
rigorous criteria and so we have to
remind people that you can't test out of
a positive case or you can't test out of
isolation or quarantine here at the
university of illinois havana champaign
you have to
uh stay in isolation and quarantine for
the
designated period when that is up you
will be notified about how to get an
additional test to make sure that you're
negative and so we have to really
crack down on the those two issues as
well as uh those repeat offenders of
large parties that went beyond the uh
guidelines that the city had put into
the cities urbana and champaign they've
been wonderful
people to work with and we have a deep
and seamless relationship they work very
hard with the borrowers to raise the
legal drinking age
to for two weeks to have outdoor dining
only and to institute a significant fine
for hosting parties that were more than
the number of residents of a particular
housing unit plus 10 individuals and
there were quite a number of folks
that were violating that and we
have expelled
or not expelled we don't we can't do
that in the university of illinois we
have suspended about four or five people
so far
suspended one greek letter organization
and have on notice a number of others we
have uh
um
about roughly 100 cases that are
currently being investigated
uh for possible violations of our
conduct code so we're being as thorough
and rigorous about this as we possibly
can be
and trying to send a very strong message
that
we can't have a small number of people
that are
essentially breaking the law in many
cases and being non-compliant to put in
jeopardy
the health and safety of the
rest of the community
as well as to undermine all of the hard
work that a dedicated number of our
scientists and scholars and
administrators
have put into place
with the core
primary goal of keeping our students and
our faculty safe and i have zero
tolerance for that
and uh you know there's uh you had you
expect
not everybody to be in compliance we we
were not uh
we were not naive that there would be
people that were non-compliant in fact
our modelers had factored that into
our expectations about what the number
of cases were going to be
but i have to admit we all acknowledged
yesterday at a press conference that we
were disappointed and very surprised
that those folks who will knowingly
come out of isolation to either test out
or to do social gatherings some of them
were hosting parties and actually going
to parties
and that is what we are trying to put an
end to
well and and i mean that makes all the
sense in the world i mean my last
question
you know when you hear about the
programs you have created it's really
incredible it's actually the the most
impressive testing and contact tracing
i've heard of not just at a university
but anywhere i've heard of in in this
country
it sounds comparable to what's been
going on in places like taiwan which is
really you know best in class in the
world
have other people been contacting y'all
i mean not just universities it seems
you know not just k-12 cities states
the federal government to say can we
scale this
all of the above
absolutely because
there's way some people have put it this
is a game changer not only for the
university of illinois a better
champagne it's a game changer for our
other two institutions that we
immediately made this testing capability
available for
university of illinois chicago and our
campus in springfield and then the next
iteration of this working with tim
colleen who's the system president and
his staff
uh we are working on two paths
one is how do we expand this to the rest
of public higher education across the
state illinois has 12 13 public
education higher education system and so
we've been working to make this
available very quickly
particularly in time for the next
semester for the campuses in bloomington
and not university of illinois campuses
but the other
public freestanding systems across the
state and that was our second priority
as well as setting this up for cities
and for
other private
public entities like nursing homes uh k
through 12 education uh city governments
we're in conversation with the city of
chicago
about standing something up there
to particularly serve the
underserved
latino latinx and african-american
populations populations that we know
have a much higher
rate of mortality related to covet 19 so
we're trying to do the public good as
well because we are university of
illinois champaign
at his core and his founding is a public
land grant university i have an
obligation to do the public good and so
in addition to trying to stand it up
across the state with other universities
we have another strategy where i'm
trying to create this alliance
of universities leveraging my
relationship and the fact i'm chairman
of the board of the association of
public and land-grant university
242 of the finest public institutions
across the country
and my colleagues in the aau
uh the 64
uh
uh really
world-class research universities mainly
across not north america but two
institutions and uh in canada so you
might admit uh you might not be
surprised to know that the list of
institutions outside of establishing
alliance we've already gotten calls from
almost every major university you can
think of from my colleague
over at indiana to michigan to michigan
state wisconsin
uh places in new york across the globe
so this is a strategy that we're working
on to serve the public good but then
there is another piece of it that we
start up as a formal university related
organization who is
vetting this for use with government
agencies other states federal government
agencies
as well as corporate entities you can
imagine large companies that have large
workforce uh whether they are working
remotely or not there's it's kind of
hard to do all of your manufacturing
completely remotely they're interested
in getting it in their
management their office head office
facility but as well as manufacturing as
well so across the board i can't name a
sector that has not indicated interest
in this in the last 12 to 45 days and
particularly the interest really peaked
once we got our uh ua
ue uh e ua improved uh approved and let
me just add one other thing to to this i
failed to mention
but another innovation that we're
working on because we can't serve all of
these clients some of them have
different set of uses some of them have
the ability to set up their own
uh clear approved laboratories many of
our institutions do
but to serve a underserved community for
example or to serve a small university
to serve k-12 education that won't have
a clear approved lab
we are in the process of a prototype
that should be done in the next week or
so of a mobile cobit 19
laboratory and we indulge envision at
least a half dozen to a dozen to maybe
two dozen of these
being deployed